[Musica]
questo è il simbolo matematico
dell'infinito come sono arrivato a
questo simbolo attraverso il mio lavoro
di artista
alla fine degli anni 50 cercavo la mia
identità come persona chi sono io dove
sono perché sono e facendo questa
ricerca di identità
mi sono rivolto a una fenomenologia
tipica dell'arte che quella
dell'autoritratto per fare
l'autoritratto necessito di uno specchio
lo specchio è il punto di riferimento
per me tra l'arte e la realtà lo
specchio dice a me
che cos'è la realtà che sta di fronte
allo specchio stesso e quindi pian piano
ho trasformato la tela del quadro in
superficie specchiante questo succedeva
tra il 60 e il 61 nel 61 sono riuscito a
fare un pigmento realizzare un pigmento
specchiante che mi ha sorpreso nel
vedere che io potevo dipingere la mia
immagine direttamente guardandomi nel
quadro è lo più nello specchio che stava
di fronte o di fianco e quindi ho
cominciato a capire che la mia identità
stava in questo rapporto tra me e tutto
ciò che lo specchio propone perché lo
specchio propone tutto ciò che gli sta
di fronte dunque la realtà questa realtà
non ha limite è infinita e quindi questo
infinito dello specchio mi ha fatto
capire che c'è anche una dinamica che è
quella che impedisce alle immagine di
durare perché una immagine che io vedo
nello specchio in quel momento c'è
sì ma non c'era e poi non c'è più quindi
abbiamo una condizione di nascita e
morte contemporanee ma dite va beh è lo
specchio si ma allo specchio riflette
tutto ciò che sta davanti
per cui noi si nasce e si muore
contemporaneamente sempre in
continuazione
io continuo a vedermi nello specchio
dunque c'è una durata la durata della
mia vita e quindi ho pensato come posso
rappresentare questa vita ho fatto l'ho
fatto altro che disegnare la linea che
proponeva i due cerchi con una un terzo
incontro della linea e quindi è nata è
nata la linea che comprende i due e
certi esterni dell'infinito ma al centro
c'è il finito infinito che cos'è è la
durata è ciò che noi viviamo
continuamente per noi vediamo che
l'infinito continua a esistere anche al
centro di questa durata quindi abbiamo
questo rapporto continuo tra resistere e
non esistere tra il finito e l'infinito
la cerchi esterni rappresentano
ovviamente il prima della vita e il dopo
la vita ma al centro c'è la vita c'è la
durata dell'esistenza tutto quanto ciò
che esiste nasce e muore
ma c'è una durata c'è una nascita una
crescita e una fine è un fine quindi
abbiamo in questo simbolo una
universalità a cui ci possiamo riferire
abbiamo due estremi il prima e il dopo
ma non c'è solo il primo il dopo c'è
tutto ciò che in qualche maniera
opponendosi si si trova in condizione di
confliggere a comporsi in un terzo
elemento nella zona centrale
che è la zona della creazione avviene la
creazione al centro ci sono sempre due
elementi 22 essere 22 condizioni due
situazioni che necessitano di
incontrarsi al centro ea quel centro
fanno nascere qualcosa dunque e non
soltanto un simbolo ma è proprio una
formula è la formula della creazione
questa formula della creazione non è più
soltanto l'espressione individuare di un
artista ma è l'espressione diciamo anche
fenomenologica e anche scientifica del
fenomeno stesso della creazione questa
creazione a questo punto non è più
soltanto fatto personale dell'artista ma
è un fenomeno a cui noi tutti possiamo
fare riferimento e possiamo in qualche
maniera mettere in atto quindi la
società arriva oggi ad essere ad essere
chiamata davanti a questo simbolo della
creazione a proporre forme nuove che
nascono proprio nell'unione tra gli
opposti tra le differenze e questo
accade proprio in natura per esempio
nella chimica abbiamo l'ossigeno da una
parte l'idrogeno dall'altra e al centro
abbiamo l'acqua
abbiamo per esempio il maschile e il
femminile al centro nasce una persona
che non esisteva perché se già esisteva
non era creazione
abbiamo un modo di intendere che può
essere diciamo relazionato a una
positività ma dall'altra parte c'è
qualcuno che la pensa in modo diverso
quindi noi dobbiamo anche capovolgere la
situazione e vediamo come tra la tesi
nostra è l'antitesi altrui può nascere
la sintesi
la sintesi è sempre creazione questo
questo fenomeno ci porta a una
conclusione molto pratica che è quella
di tradurre di tradurre la questo
concetto di fondo
in pratica perché noi siamo sempre molto
molto portati a immaginare delle
meraviglie però dobbiamo riuscire a
farle diventare pratica la pratica per
me è la democrazia
come nasce questo questo termine abbiamo
abbiamo la democrazia da una parte c'è è
considerata è considerata una promessa
della dell'umanità ma questa democrazia
è fatta di due parole demo e kratos
allora demos vuol dire popolo kratos
vuol dire potere il potere del popolo
non è possibile se noi pensiamo che il
popolo è fatto da tantissime persone le
quali i divi divise l'una dall'altra non
possono avere potere quindi nella
dualità che io esprimo con questo
simbolo devo mettere devo mettere due
elementi insieme che possono unirsi ea
100 creare un qualche cosa che non
esisteva
dunque questo lo devo fare il senso
pratico per praticare la democrazia deve
usare un termine che è praxis praxis
vuol dire pratica al demo's e praxis
fanno democrazia
devo trovare in questo modo un metodo
democratico per far funzionare questa
democrazia
la demo pratica non sostituisce la
democrazia ma è la via reale per
arrivarci
allora come si pratica la democrazia con
tre punti di attività
la prima è la mappatura
la mappatura di tutti gli organismi
esistenti non non i partiti non le
ideologie ma io organismi esistenti le
le organizzazioni le organizzazioni
economiche e produttive e scolastiche di
tutti i tipi di attività tutti attività
di profit e no profit quelle cose che
esistono esistono comunque ci sono
proprio queste attività che viviamo
tutti quanti quotidianamente ci sono il
livello di base che ci permette di
mettere insieme attraverso dei forum
delle organizzazioni di scambio e di
definizione di problematiche legate
anche con quelli che sono i 17 obiettivi
onu per la sostenibilità e quindi siamo
al punto di di una trasformazione del
sistema politico che passa dalla
concessione partitico ideologica alla
concessione di pratica la pratica c'è in
ogni ogni organizzazione ogni
associazione nella società ha un suo
piccolo governo ha una sua piccola
organizzazione parlamentare così come
ogni famiglia ha un piccolo parlamento
quindi ogni settore della vita sociale è
fatto di famiglia famiglia famiglia
famiglia tutte queste famiglie insieme
possono in qualche maniera in contrario
si con i forum dunque esiste il cantiere
alla fine che il forum porta ha come
conseguenza durante tutto l'anno si
lavora per mettere insieme le proposte
fatte dai forum e ci sono altri piccoli
forme di forum
di settore che vengono portati avanti
quindi la politica non è più qualcosa
che si demanda ma è qualcosa che si fa
direttamente non è possibile farla
individualmente è necessario essere
almeno in due
la dualità si organizza in maniera che
si possano poi realizzare le attività
del forum
[Applauso]